[Music]
good evening I'm Conan O'Brien president
of the Conan show as you know we face a
government crisis as we tape this
segment right now our government has
shut down and all non-essential
personnel have been furloughed they've
been laid off well I thought in keeping
with the times and to support my country
I should probably also lay off all
non-essential personnel here at the
Conan show by the way I'm wearing this
Guinness top right here this little
fleece in the hopes that Guinness will
see it and give me free Guinness what
are you doing right now
simple things what is it for sandwich
shop okay is this something that I asked
for no is this for me no so this is a
sandwich that would be for you yeah it's
a pie you weren't by a pie you want to
buy a pie for yourself so as I'm looking
for who's non-essential I come across
you and you're what is it buying a pie
online would you say that you are
essential personnel so no okay
what's the deal here are you doing a
crossword puzzle of your desk
uh no this is your handwriting yes and
this is a crossword puzzle I'm sitting
on your desk so you were doing a
crossword puzzle on your desk don't you
can't lie in front of the camera
you can't lie what are you stuck on
what's the worry just tell us which one
it is and then you know this ends up on
the thing then people are gonna think
I'm stupid for not knowing it I just
don't okay okay a three-letter word for
vehicle that starts with C is car I
assist the executive producing what
kinds of things do you assist him in
doing just running his life hoping
answers phone mm-hm is there anyone here
on staff what you think is non-essential
if you had to give up one name who do
you think is non-essential anthe Jordan
Jordan is non-essential yeah whites what
does he do I don't know I just always
see him filling up his Brita so if I was
to let someone go and staff you would
recommend that it is me and you don't
feeling all guilty giving up his name no
Breanna ask you is there one
non-essential person on the staff
someone who you feel probably doesn't do
that much and could be eliminated just
one yeah if i had you had to yeah yeah i
mean i don't even know what he does it
must be a real douche
you describe your duties on the show
please uh I overlook the whole IT
infrastructure that's a big song
overlooked IT infrastructure that you
get your email rather than the staff is
non-essential don't be afraid to give a
name think about it non-essential
non-essential who could go if they had
to go beyond just be really honest
there's a name that popped into your
head he's my friend who is it
I say join us like oh no one is prompted
in any way this is the name this is
unbelievable so George less he is the
name that you my buddy
yes Billy manna hope you and I are never
good friends
where's Kramer you just came downstairs
you went downstairs yeah I'm looking for
a non-essential personnel my guess is
when someone's not at their desk they're
probably non-essential would you agree I
guess so yeah you just sold out the guy
you sit next to it yeah Jordan yes
please Stan
you and I have talked many times over
the years but this is serious okay I'm
talking to everyone on staff one name
has come up repeatedly I believe nine
times people don't know what you do
they don't understand your job you fill
your Brita filter with water is this in
fact the water that's often being filled
in the hallway the choice to remain
hydrated doesn't imply that I have no
work to do
how much is what anything today 78
ounces what are you a weeping willow
here are your tree that's a ton of water
how much they are you urinating then how
many times you go to the bathroom drain
you ideally once an hour you urinate
once an hour why ideally once an hour
well I have to make sure my urine is
almost clear you drink seventy eight
ounces of water a day after you more
than seventy eight ounces of water a day
I drink seventy eight ounces of water
while I'm here how much what are you
thinking a day but double 78 correct you
drink a hundred and sixty some odd
ounces of water a day
156 every time I ask you what you do and
we've had numerous remotes where I've
talked to you numerous times you use the
word numerous various assorted but you
never give one specific thing what do
you do if you're not gonna tell me who
are you going to tell the people that
need to know already no what do you mean
that's me Jordan are you essential yes
or no yes were you to disappear now man
is it tempting
with the show be affected with the
exception of yourself I could argue that
any particular staff member can be
eliminated with no visible results on
air you have the body language as Lee
Harvey Oswald
[Applause]
[Music]